[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم في دباسيل
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من الخرطوم وهذه
الصور في نهايه يوم شهد تبادلا للقصف بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في
مناطق متفرقه بالعاصمه وهذه الصور من
فرنسا التي تبيت عاصمتها باريس ومدن اخرى
على وقع مظاهرات للتنديد بمشروع قانون
الهجره الجديد
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
التصعيد الاسرائيلي في الضفه يتواصل قوات
الاحتلال تقتحم منطقه جبل الطويل وتقتل
فلسطينيا وتصيب اخره اضراب شامل ومواجهات
مع الاحتلال في رام الله والبيريه وترحيب
فلسطيني بادانه لجنه التحقيق الامميه
لانتهاكات الاحتلال
في خضم معارك محتديمه في الخرطوم قصف
متبادل بين الجيش والدعم واستهداف لمحيط
القياده العامه البرهان يقول ان الشرطه
تقاتل الى جانب القوات المسلحه ويتم الدعم
للمره الاولى بالمسؤوليه عن فض اعتصام
القياده العامه سنه 2019
ومقتل عشرات المحتجين
في الولايات المتحده افلات مؤقت من شبح
اغلاق حكوميا يشل المؤسسات الفيدراليه
مجلس النواب يمرروا مشروع قانون تمويلا ل
45 يوما تمهيدا لتصويت مجلس الشيوخ
ومكارتي يقول ان الاولويه لابقاء الوكالات
الحكوميه في حاله عمل
زيلينسكي يعلن التوجه لتوسيع صنع الاسلحه
محليا بالتعاون مع شركات غربيه ورئيس
وزرائه يؤكد رفع الانفاق على الانتاج
الدفاعي سبعه اضعاف يقول ان روسيا ستواصل
عمليتها العسكريه وستضم المزيد من الاراضي
في اوكرانيا
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا الامر الذي اصدره مكتب
النائب العام الليبي بحبسه اربعه مسؤولين
بعد توجيه تهم اليهم بالتقصير ما ادى الى
خسائر كبيره في الارواح والممتلكات جراء
الفيضانات غير المسبوقه
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي بعد اصدار
مكتب النائب العام الليبي بامرا بحبس
اربعه مسؤولين على خلفيه كارثه فيضانات
درنه هل تحقق الخطوه المطالبه المتزايده
بالمحاسبه في اكبر كارثه تشهدها ليبيا
22% اعتبروا ان خطوه النائب العام ستفتح
ملف المحاسبه بينما راى 78% انها لا تتعدى
كونها خطوه شكليه
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
قانون جديد للهجره في فرنسا يثير احتجاجات
واسئله
[موسيقى]
البدايه من الاراضي الفلسطينيه حيث تتواصل
الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه لمدن وبلدات الضفه
الغربيه فقد قالت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
ان شابا فلسطينيا استشهد متاثرا بجروح
اصيب بها الليله الماضيه نتيجه اطلاق جنود
الاحتلال النار عليه في منطقه جبل الطويل
في البيرين واوضحت الوزاره ان فلسطينيا
اخر اصيب بجروحه وقد اعتصم فلسطينيون وسط
مدينه رام الله حدادا على روح الشهيد محمد
رمانه وكان جنود الاحتلال قد تركوا محمد
رمانه ورفيقه محمد ربيع ينزفان عقب اطلاق
النار عليهما ومنع اسعافهما
كما شهدت مدينه رام الله والبير احتجاجات
تندد بقتل قوات الاحتلال للفتى الفلسطيني
وقال الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني ان عشره
فلسطينيين اصيبوا بحالات اغماء جراء قمع
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للاحتجاجات
واستهدفت قوات الاحتلال المحتجين بقنابل
الغاز قبل ان يرشق قوات الاحتلال بالحجاره
هذا ولا تزال قوات الاحتلال تحتجز جثمان
الشهيد روماني وتعتقل محمد ربيع رغم
اصابته وطالبت والده الشهيد محمد جبريل
رمانه في مداخله سابقه مع الجزيره طالبت
بتسليم جثمان ابنها لدفنه
ادفنون اخر مره واشوفه وهذا هي بس شو بدي
اطالب الله يرضى عليك
الله يسامحك كان حنون كثير وطيب ومحبوب
عند الجميع ما بزعلش حدا
كثير هادي الله يرضى عليه كثير كثير بحبش
المشاكل
الله يرضى عليك مصيبه بس انا بطالب انه
مين مختص في هاي الشؤون اني بس اشوف ما
بدي اكثر عن هيك
ومع توالي الجيش الاحتلال لمدن الضفه
الغربيه نعيد في العرض التالي تسليط الضوء
على تقسيم مناطق الدفاع وافقت اتفاقاتي
لطبيعه العلاقه الامنيه الاسرائيليه مع كل
قسمه
[موسيقى]
بشكل شبهي يومي تتكرر الاقتحامات
الاسرائيليه لمدن ومخيمات في الضفه
الغربيه بذريعه مطارده مقاومين فلسطينيين
لكن هل تملك السلطات الاحتلال المسوغه
لتلك الاقتحامات منذ ثلاثه عقود وقعت
اتفاقيه اوسلو الاولى وبعدها بعامين
لحقتها الثانيه والتي قسمت الضفه الغربيه
لثلاث مناطق الف وباء وجيم تشكل المنطقه
الف نحو 18% من مساحه الضفه وتضم ابرز
مدنها وهي نابلس وجنين وطولكرم وقلقيليه
ورمى الله وبيت لحم واريحا وثمانين في
المئه من مدينه الخليل نصت اوسلو على كمال
السيطره الفلسطينيه على هذه المنطقه بما
في ذلك الجوانب الامنيه وعلى حظر دخول
قوات اسرائيليه او اسرائيليين لكن خلال
الانتفاضه الثانيه وخلال عمليه السور
الواقي تحديدا عام 2002 الغى الاحتلال هذا
الحظر وماتت قواته توالي المداهمات وان
كانت تنسيق مع السلطه الفلسطينيه اما
المنطقه ب فتشكل دحم 21% من مساحه الضفه
وتخضع اداريا فقط للسلطه الفلسطينيه
وامنيا للاحتلال الاسرائيلي بينما تشكل
المنطقه جيم المساحه المتبقيه اي ما يقارب
واحد وستين في المئه من مساحه الضفه وهي
تحت السيطره الاسرائيليه بالكامل ويتمدد
بها الوجود الاستيطاني اللافت ان الميزان
السكاني الفلسطينيه بصفه متعاكس مع تلك
القسمه فبينما يعيش 90% من الفلسطينيين
بالمنطقه الف يعيش عشره في المئه فقط في
المنطقه جيم يبقى ان توالي الاقتحامات
الاسرائيليه فضلا عن شبكات طرق انشاها
الاحتلال بطول 980 كيلومترا لم يفتت فقط
منطقتي الف وباء بل جعل عمليات اقتحام
مناطقهما وخاصه مدن المنطقه الف اكثر
سهوله وروتينيه
[موسيقى]
في هذه الاثناء رحبت الخارجيه الفلسطينيه
بموقف اللجنه الامميه بشان ادانه انتهاكات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بحق الشعب الفلسطيني
وطالبت في بيان بفرض عقوبات على اسرائيل
لوقف انتهاكاتها بدورها رحبت حركه حماس
بموقف اللجنه وضعت المجتمع الدولي الى
اتخاذ اجراءات مناسبه لمحاسبه الاحتلال
على ضوء النتائج التي خلصت اليها اللجنه
وكانت لجنه التحقيق الدوليه التابعه للامم
المتحده قد اصدرت امس ورقه اكدت فيها ان
الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه بحق الفلسطينيين
تستوجب عواقب قانونيه عاجله
ينضم الينا من رام الله الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه دكتور مصطفى الانتهاكات
الاسرائيليه تزداد وتيرتها منذ بدايه هذا
العام اقتحامات توسيع للاستيطان تحويل
القدس لسكنه عسكريه بمناسبه ما يعرف بعيد
العرش كل ذلك الى ماذا يرمي وما الهدف منه
واي رسائل يحمل
هدف النشاطات الاسرائيليه الاجراميه ثلاثه
الهدف الاول استكمال عمليه ضم وتهويد
الضفه الغربيه بما فيها القدس بالكامل عبر
التوسيع الشرس للاستيطان وعبر عمليه
التهجير الفعليه التي بداتها فيما يسمى
منطقه جيم حيث حتى هذه اللحظه وحسب تقارير
الامم المتحده
ارهاب المستوطنين بحمايه جيش الاحتلال ادى
الى ترحيل عشرين
تجمع سكاني يبلغ عدد افراده 1100 شخص وهذه
مساله خطيره لم تحدث منذ عام 48 تطهير
عرقي جديد الامر الثاني اسرائيل تستخدم كل
ما لديها من طاقات من اجل بالقمع والتنكيل
في محاوله لكسر المقاومه الفلسطينيه
المشتده من قبل جيل شاب لا يؤمن الا
بالنضال والكفاح والمقاومه وفي هذا طبعا
تفشل اسرائيل ولكنها تصعد اعتداءاتها
ثالثا اسرائيل تقوم باجتياح كل المناطق
يعني فقط في هذا اليوم اجتاحوا قاموا
بالاعتداء على مناطق البيره على تقوع
النبي صالح طولكرم وارتاح ولا يتبرعوا عن
الدخول كما ذكرتم الى مناطق الف او باء او
غيرها
وهم يحاولوا ان يفرضوا واقع جديد في
الواقع ليس للسلطه الفلسطينيه اي سيطره
حقيقيه وانما هي واقعه بالكامل تحت
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وفي نفس الوقت يمارسه عليها ضغوطا هائله
لكي تعمق التنسيق الامني معهم من الواضح
ان هنالك خطه ممنهجه
القيام بخطوات محدده تهدف الى اختزال حقوق
الفلسطينيين الوطنيه المنطقه جيم كما ذكرت
ولكن ما هي الادوات لمواجهه ذلك
اولا يعني طبعا يجب ان اضيف الى ما ذكرته
مساله اخرى تقوم بها اسرائيل وهي استخدام
التطبيع التطبيع مع المحيط العربي
يستخدم كخنجر يطعن ظهر النضال الوطني
الفلسطيني وايضا يستخدم كوسيله
لتهميش القضيه الفلسطينيه والعمل على
تصفيتها وهذا هو مخطط نتنياهو الرد على
ذلك لا يمكن الا ان يكون بالمقاومه مقاومه
هذه المخططات بكل الاشكال
المقاومه على الارض والمقاومه على الصعيد
الدولي
التقرير الذي ذكرتموه من قبل الامم
المتحده والذي يقر بان اسرائيل تواصل
الانتهاكات في اطول احتلال في التاريخ
البشري الحديث
ويدعو دول العالم الى اتخاذ اجراءات كما
سماها عواقب قانونيه لوضع حد لهذا الفعل
غير المشروع يعني نحن نترجم ذلك الى شيء
واحد محدد يمكن ان يكون فعال وهو فرض
العقوبات والمقاط وسحب الاستثمارات من هذا
الكيان المعتدي الذي يخرق كل القوانين
الدوليه لذلك لا يوجد حل الا الجمع ما بين
المقاومه والمقاطعه بالاضافه بالاضافه الى
توحيد الصف الوطني على برنامج وطني كفاحي
مقاوم واستراتيجيه دكتور مروان يعني تحويل
ما سميته بمقاومه دوليه يحتاج الى روافع
منها توحيد الصف الفلسطيني هل هذا محقق
الان ماذا عن القوى الدوليه وموازين القوه
الدوليه ماذا عن الدعم العربي للقضيه
الفلسطينيه هل هذه المعايير والشروط محققه
شوف اولا الاخت فداء يعني اولا بالنسبه
للجانب
المصالحه الداخليه للاسف غير متحققه حتى
الان ولن تتحقق الا باتفاق جميع القوى
الفلسطينيه على ان الحل هو نهج كفاحي
مقاوم وليس المراهنه على مفاوضات عقيمه او
على حل وسط مع الحركه الصهيونيه على
الصعيد الدولي حركه المقاطعه تحقق نجاحات
كبيره جدا على الصعيد الشعبي على صعيد
النقابات على صعيد المجتمع المدني على
صعيد الكنائس حتى الكنيسه الانجليكانيه
مؤخرا في جنوب افريقيا اتخذت قرارا قاطعا
بفرض المقاطعه على اسرائيل نحن نحقق
نجاحات كل يوم ولكن الحكومات ما زالت
بعيده عن المشاركه في هذه المقاطعه وهذا
سيتحقق بمواصله الضغط ولكن ايضا بموقف
رسمي فلسطيني حازم من هذا الامر نقطه
اخيره اريد ان اشير لها التقرير للامم
المتحده يقول يقول باختصار يقول انه من
الواجب فرض المقاطعه وليس التطبيع مع هذا
الكيان الاسرائيلي شكرا لك دكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العامل المبادرات الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه كنت معنا مره
[موسيقى]
تحتدم المعارك في قلب الخرطوم ويشتد القصف
في محيط القياده العامه التي تعود الى
الواجهات الميدانيه مجددا وافادت مصادر
محليه للجزيره بان الجيش السوداني قصف
مواقع للدعم السريع بمحيط سلاح المدرعات
في الاثناء قال رئيس مجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان ان الشرطه تقاتل الى جانب
الجيش ضد ما يريدون ابتلاع الدوله
السودانيه وتحيدها لمصالحهم الخاصه من
جانب اخر وفي اول اتهام من نوعه قال
البرهان ان قوات الدعم السريع هي من فضى
اعتصام القياده العامه عام 2019
ينتصف الشهر السادس والنزاع المسلح بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع باقي
على ما هو عليه من اعمال عنف وقصف
واشتباكات متبادله وتتحدث المصادر عن
تبادل القصف بين الجانبين منذ صباح السبت
على مواقع تمركزهما بمدن العاصمه
السودانيه الثلاث وسمع دوي انفجارات قويه
بمحيط القياده العامه للجيش كما ذكر الجيش
انه قصف مواقع الدعم بمحيط سلاح المدرعات
جنوبي الخرطوم وقال رئيس مجلس السياده
وقائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان ان الشرطه
تقاتل الى جانب الجيش ضد من وصفهم
بالراغبين في ابتلاع الدوله وتحيدها
لمصالحهم الخاصه واكد التصميم على انهاء
ما سماه التمرد المسلح حربا او سلما
وبطريقه تحفظ كرامه المواطنين وشدد على ان
من وصفهم بالميليشيات اذا ارادت حلا
فيتعين عليها الخروج من منازل المواطنين
والمنشات المدنيه وقال البرهان لاول مره
ان قوه الدعم السريع هي من فضت اعتصام
القياده العامه عام 2019
وكان مسلحون قد اقتحموا حينئذ مقر
الاعتصام وفرقوا باستخدام الاسلحه الثقيله
والخفيفه والغاز المسيء للدموع المعتصمين
المدنيين السلميين مما تسبب في مقتل وجرح
وفقدان المئات ولاحقا كشف الخبير القانوني
نبيل اديب رئيس لجنه التحقيق في فض
الاعتصام عن تاثر كبير لاعمال اللجنه بعد
استقاله رئيس الوزراء عبد الله حمدوك ثم
توقف اللجنه تماما عن ممارسه مهامها بعد
استيلاء قوات امنيه على مقرها ومنع
العاملين من الدخول من ناحيه اخرى ذكر ان
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا والنرويج
والمانيا تعتزم التقدم بطلب الى مجلس حقوق
الانسان التابع للامم المتحده لاجراء
تحقيق في مختلف ملابسات النزاع في السودان
والمناطق المتضرره وشكل الاضرار ومن بين
هذه المناطق غرب دارفور التي اودت فيها
هجمات عرقيه نسبت لقوات الدعم السريع
ومؤيديها بحياه المئات ونزوح ولجوء الالاف
ودمار مدينه الجنينه عاصمه الولايه وقتل
والي الولايه والتمثيل بجثته لكن الدعم
السريع ينفي هذه الاتهامات ويشدد على انه
سيقدم للعداله اي جندي من عناصره يثبت
تورطه فيها ويمكن في حال طرح الطلب ان
يفتح الطريق ايضا امام تحقيق لجان دوليه
مستقله في اتهامات الجيش للدعم السريع
بالاستيلاء على منازل المواطنين والمنشات
المدنيه ومن شان ذلك اضافه معطيات جديده
لاي مفاوضات قادمه بين الجانبين حيث
ستنبني على وقائع تلك اللجان بعيدا عن
الاتهامات المتبادله بين الجانبين في
الجولات السابقه
محمد طورشين الكاتب والباحثه السياسيه
السوداني سيد محمد تورشين ما الغايه او
الدافع من وراء اتهام او تحميل قوات الدعم
السريع مسؤوليه فض اعتصام القياده العامه
في هذا التوقيت
هو بلال شبكات ودوافع سياسيه من قبل رئيس
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان وهو
عندما كان رئيس اللجنه العسكريه او للمجلس
العسكري وقع فض هذا الاعتصام فبالتالي هو
ايضا يتحمل المسؤوليه الاخلاقيه
والمسؤوليه المهنيه المرتبطه بفضل
الاعتصام لكن تحميله للمزوليه لقبر قوات
الدعم السريعه والمعلوم التي هي شاركت
بعناصرها وافرادها وعندي اذن ان كنت حضورا
في ساحه الاعتصام اؤكد لك بان الدعم سريع
هو الذي فضل الاعتصام وضلالنا نؤكد ونثبت
هذه المعلومات لكن
يعني كانت هنالك لجنه تحقيق شكلت هذه
اللجنه اكثر من مره وتم التعديل عليها
وعرقل عملها الكشف عن هذه المعلومات الان
ما الهدف منها
الهدف منه مزيد من التوريط للدعم السريع
وكذلك محاوله لفرد طاقه من الرفض الشعبي
والجماهير الى الدعم السريع باعتبار انه
الان الحربي مفتوحه وان كان على جانب
الدعايه والحرب الاعلاميه فضلا عن الحرب
العسكريه بهذا الامر انا في تقدير يزعل
البرهان لتحميل الدعم السريع كل المسؤوليه
الاخلاقيه المرتبطه بفضل الاعتصام وكذلك
ومحاوله ارسال رسائل للقوه السياسيه التي
ظلت تؤكد على ضروره ان يكون التحقيق عادلا
وتحديد المسؤوليه الجنائيه للشخص الذي
اصدر الاوامر والجهات التي نفذت بحيث ان
هذه جريمه مهمه جدا في تاريخ السياسي ولها
التبعات او ربما هذه من الجرائم التي
تطالب الكثير بادراجها ضمن لجنه التحقيق
دوليه او حتى احالتها عليه المحكمه
الجنائي الدوليه بهذا التصريح انا في
تقديري ربما يرغب البرهان في تحديد مسار
لجنه
الخبراء او كذلك
للتحقيق الذي فتحته المحكمه الج نائيه
الديوانيه مؤخرا طيب
ميدانيا وعلى الارض في المعارك الدائره
بانه لا يمكن لاي احد ان يرفض التسويه لكن
الشروط الذي وضعها للتسويه هي ربما التي
تتحدث عن الكرامه
التنظيف ذلك امام الجهات الدوليه ولكن
ماذا عن المسؤوليه السياسيه والصمت منذ
2019 الى 2013 هل يمكن يعني عدم تحمل
المسؤوليه في مثل هكذا حاله
انا في البرهان منذ خروجه من القياده
العامه وفي الجولات الاقليميه وكذلك خطابه
في جميع العامه للامم المتحده ولقاء
انتهاء بهذه التصريحات يرغم في اعاده
تسويق نفسه سياسيا للمنظومه الدوليه
والاسر الدوليه لا سيما تمثل قضيه اتفضل
اعتصام من اهم القضايا التي ظلت تؤكد كثير
من القوه وكذلك مجلس حقوق الانسان بضروره
ان يتم تحديد المسؤوليه الجنائيه للجهات
التي شارك قدوه اصدرت هذه القوارض
وبالتالي هذا التصريح يجعل البرهان من
خلاله التنصل من المسؤوليه الجنائيه بشكل
مباشر لانه كان هو رئيس مجلس السياده
عندئذ
الكاتب والباحث السياسيه السوداني كنت
معنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
في الولايات المتحده ابتعد ابتعد مؤقتا
شبحوا الاغلاق الحكومي بعد ان مرر مجلس
النواب مشروع قانونا لتمويل الوكالات
الحكوميه لمده 45 يوما لتفادي شلل
المؤسسات الفيدراليه ولا يتضمن الاجراء
الذي ينص على تمويل الوكالات الحكوميه ل
45 يوما اي تمويل للمساعدات لاوكرانيا وقد
تم التصويت لصالح مشروع القانون باغلبيه
335 صوتا مقابل 91 وحظي هذا الاجراء الذي
قدمه رئيس مجلس النواب كيفن مكارتي بدعم
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين على حد سواء حيث
صوت ضده نائب ديمقراطي واحد وتسعون
جمهوريا هذا ويتضمن التمويل المؤقت اموالا
للاغاثه في حالات الكوارث وتمديدا لبرنامج
التامين الفيدرالي ضد الفيضانات وسيحتاج
موافقه مجلس الشيوخ قبل منتصف الليل حسب
التوقيت الش رقي للولايات المتحده لتجنب
الاغلاق الحكومي
هذا وقال رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن
مكارتي ان الاولويه هي ابقاء المؤسسات
والهيئات الحكوميه في حاله عمل واشدد
مكارتي في تصريحات صحفيه على الابقاء على
المؤسسات الحكوميه مفتوحه مؤكدا ان مشاريع
القوانين التي مررها مجلس النواب هي
الاكثر تحفظا على الاطلاق
ينضم الينا من الكونجرس مراسل جزيره مراد
هاشم مراد اذا مشروع القانون امام مجلس
الشيوخ المسيره والمسار التي مر به هذا
القانون ليصل الى مجلس الشيوخ
مرحبا فداء بالفعل الكره الان في ملعب
مجلس الشيوخ الان الاعضاء الجمهوريون
يدفعون للتصويت على هذا المشروع بطبيعه
الحال الذي صوت ايضا لصالحه في مجلس
النواب 200 من المشرعين الديمقراطيين
كان هناك مشروع مطروح امام مجلس الشيوخ
يتضمن دعما ومساعده لاوكرانيا وكان يحظى
بدعم من الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
الاغلبيه في الواقع 80 صوتا لكن زعيم
الاقلي الجمهوريه في مجلس الشيوخ قال
قبيله التصويت في مجلس النواب من انه في
حال طرح هذا المشروع فانه سوف يصوت بناء
الجمهوريون سوف يصوتون بلا عليه لان هناك
مشروع اخر مفضل لديه مطروح امام مجلس
النواب وهذا المشروع هو الذي امر الذي مر
في مجلس النواب هذه الاغلبيه الكبيره وان
لم يتضمن في الواقع اي مساعدات لاوكرانيا
لكن هناك على ما يبدو صفقه ابرمت معك بين
مكارتي على ان تقدم يقدم مشروع منفصل خلال
الايام القليله المقبله
نعم في حال لم يتم الموافقه على مشروع
القانون كما تقول بعد 45 يوما ما الذي
سيجري
مشروع القانون الذي مر في مجلس النواب على
الارجح بدرجه كبيره سيمر من مجلس الشيوخ
اتحدث عن هذا المشروع
لان اغلبيه من الديمقراطيين صوتت لصالحه
في مجلس النواب البيت الابيض ابدى ارتياحا
من هذه الخطوه وبالتالي هذه مؤشرات تعطي
تعطي التوجهات ان التوجهات في مجلس الشيوخ
ستكون في ذات الاتجاه وبالتالي هناك مساعي
الان
بطبيعه الحال لاجراء التصويت على هذا
المشروع الذي مر في مجلس النواب في مجلس
الشيوخ من اجل اعتماده وبالتالي عرضه على
مكتب الرئيس بايدن للمصادقه عليه ومن ثم
تجنب الاغلاق الحكومي الذي لا يريده
الحزبان كما
يعلن الاغلبيه بطبيعه الحال من الطرفين
لكن هذا يفتح ايضا مجالا لمعارك اخرى
جانبيه بينها تلك المعركه التي قد نشهدها
قريبا خلال ايام بين القله من الجمهوريين
من انصاد ترامب وكبن مكارثي احدهم هدده
باجراء تصويت لعزله من منصبه وقد نرى بذلك
خطوه عمليه كما يتوقع كثيرون خلال ايام
كنت معنا من الكونجرس
ماذا يعني الاغلاق الحكوميه واي القطاعات
يعنيها وما تاثيره على الامريكيين ومستقبل
الاقتصاد اسئله تتبادر كل ما اخفق
المشرعون الديمقراطيون والجمهوريون في
التوافق على تمويل الحكومه للعام المالي
الجديد الذي يبدا في اكتوبر تشرين الاول
نقترب اكثر من الاغلاق وتبعاته في هذا
التقرير
[موسيقى]
ولن يحصل الملايين منهم واعضاء الخدمه
العسكريه على رواتبهم لكن الموظفين
الاساسيين مثل العاملين في الخدمات التي
تحمي السلامه العامه او الامن القومي
يستمرون في العمل مع ان الاغلاق في الماضي
شمل خدمات مثل تطبيق القانون الفيدرالي
سيستمر توزيع مدفوعات الضمان الاجتماعي
لكبر السن والامريكيين ذوي الاعاقه وغيرهم
كما ستتواصل خدمه البريد بشكل منتظم تشير
التقديرات الى ان نحو مليون وثمانمائه الف
موظف قد لا يحصلون على رواتب خلال فتره
الاغلاق وسيمنح نحو 850 الفا من الموظفين
غير الاساسيين اجازه من دون راتب ونتيجه
لغياب هؤلاء الموظفين فان العديد من
الخدمات تتوقف او تتباطئ ومنها المتنزهات
الوطنيه والمتاحف التي تعمل بتمويل
فيدرالي ويمكن ان تزداد تاخيره رحلات
الجويه بسبب نقص العاملين في اداره امن
النقل
مراقب الحركه الجويه بالعوده للوراء
استمرت اطول فتره من شلل الميزانيه في
الولايات المتحده 35 يوما بين ديسمبر
كانون الاول 2018 ويناير كانون الثاني
2019 وفق مكتب الميزانيه غير الحزبي
بالكونغرس كلف الاغلاق الجزئي نحو 11
مليار دولار وقلص من توقعات النمو
الاقتصادي السنوي للبلاد بصفر فاصل اثنين
في المئه للاغلاق عواقب اقتصاديه بعيده
المدى تعزز حاله عدم اليقين وتشمل رفع
معدل البطاله وخفض نمو الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي ورفعت تكلفه الاقتراض وفي مثل
هذه الحاله يتوقف مكتب احصاءات العمل عن
نشر البيانات مثل الارقام الرئيسيه حول
التضخم والبطاله لهذا سرع مسؤولون في
البيت الابيض للقول ان الاغلاق يضع اكبر
اقتصاد في العالم امام خطر لا داعي له
[موسيقى]
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قال
الرئيس الاوكراني ان اولويه بلاده الان هي
تطوير الانتاج الدفاعي باستخدام التقنيات
الحديثه وانتاج الصواريخ والمسيارات
بالتعاون مع الشركات العالميه جاءت
التصريحات خلال منتدى في كييفا للصناعات
الدفاعيه بمشاركه 165 شركه عالميه من
جانبه قال رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني ان
بلاده تخطط لانفاق مليار ونصف المليار
دولار على انتاج الاسلحه العامه المقبل اي
بزياده سبعه اضعاف عن حجم الانفاق عام
اوكرانيا تسعى لان تتحول الى مركز عسكري
كبير لتوطين انتاج السلاح من خلال شراكه
مع مصنع اسلحه غربيه ولهذا الغرض جمعت
كييف نحو 250 من شركات التصنيع الدفاعي
العالميه من 30 دوله في مكان واحد
فاوكرانيا تعتمد على الدعم المالي
والعسكري الغربي وحصلت على اسلحه وعتاد
تقدر قيمته بنحو 80 مليار دولار لكن طول
امد الحرب افرز نمو مضطرضا في الطلب على
اسلحه وذخيره قد يعني هذا ان الدعم الغربي
لكييف قد يشهد تحولا
فبدلا من ارسال اسلحه وذخائر من الحلفاء
سيكون انتاجها في اوكرانيا هذه المعطيات
قد تؤشر الى ان الحرب قد تطول لذا
فاوكرانيا بحاجه لاعطاء دفعه للاقتصاد
المحلي كما سيمكنها توطين التصنيع من
الحصول على ما تحتاج اليه
وتشير المعلومات الوارده من كييف انها
وقعت بالفعل مجموعه من الاتفاقيات مع
شركاء غربيين للانتاج المشترك وتبادل
التكنولوجيا وتوليد مكونات التصنيع بينما
كشف عدد من كبار المنتجين الغربيين من
المانيا وبريطانيا تحديدا عن خطه للتعاون
مع المنتجين الاوكرانيين فيما بقيت اسماء
شركات اخرى طي الكتمان ولتحقيق مفهوم
توطين الانتاج من المرجح ان تتولى الدول
الغربيه تمويل راس المال الاوكراني وتسهيل
حصولك على رخص استخدام نماذج الاسلحه
وتمتلك كييف بالفعل تصنيعا عسكريا محدودا
قبل بضعه اسابيع اعلنت انها طورت واجرت
تجربه ناجحه لصاروخ اصاب هدفه على بعد 700
كيلومتر اوكرانيا تعتبر وريثا لنحو 30% من
مؤسسات الانتاج العسكري السوفييتيه ومن
هذا الارث الكبير شركات استراتيجيه مثل
ومصنع ماليشييفا ومصنع موتور سيتش وكانت
اوكرانيا تحتل المركز الرابع عالميا في
تصدير الاسلحه والعتاد العسكري قبل
السيطره روسيا على اقليم دوبلس وتتركز
الصناعات العسكريه حاليا فيزا بولوجيا
تحديدا حيث مصنع لانتاج محركات مسيرات
بيرقدار التركيه بينما تنتج المسيرات
الاوكرانيه في ميك ولايف
[موسيقى]
في الجانب الروسي اكد نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن القومي ديمتري ان روسيا ستسيطر على
اراضي اضافيه في اوكرانيا واضاف ان
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا
ستستمر حتى فناء ما وصفه النظام النازي في
كييف بشكل كامل حسب تعبيره واكد متفاده
فان النصر سيكون حليفه موسكو وستضم مناطق
جديده الى روسيا
ينضموا الينا من موسكو فلاديمير يارا
نوسيان الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي ومن
ويسكنسن العقيدز المستشار السابق لوزيره
الدفاع الامريكي لشؤون اوكرانيا عقيده
توطين الانتاج انتاج الاسلحه في اوكرانيا
هل هو بديل عن مساعدات الاسلحه التي
يقدمها الغرب لاوكرانيا
بدون اوكرانيا تعرف ان الحرب سيطول امدها
ولن تنتهي الان بالتالي سيقل يقل اعتمادهم
على الاسلحه المقدمه لهم من الدول الغربيه
وبالتالي هم يريدون ان يقوموا بزياده
انتاج الاسلحه محليا ولكن تمويل راس المال
ياتي من الغرب الا يبقي ذلك اوكرانيا
رهينه لقرارات الغرب
على الاطلاق عندما يبداون ببدايه ببناء
امكانياتهم
وهم سيعتمدون بدايه على المساعدات الغربيه
بعد ذلك سيكون سيكون انتاجهم لهذه الاسلحه
بشكل مستقل طيب ننوه بدايه الى هذا العاجل
الوارد امامنا على الشاشه التلغراف تنقل
عن وزير دفاع بريطانيا
سننقل
برنامجا تدريبيا بقيادتنا لاوكرانيا بدل
الاعتماد على قواعد اعضاء الناتو كيف
تقراون ذلك عقيديا
يا امين
اعتقد انهم يريدون ان يستمروا بالنظر الى
اليه مختلفه لكي يستطيعوا بها تدريب
الجنود الاوكرانيين ربما عن طريق النيتو
او عن طريق المباشر وهم سيصلون الى
الطريقه الافضل لهذه التدريب بالتالي فان
النيتو هو يتكون من 29 دوله من الصعب
احيانا الحصول على توافقات من بين هذه
الدول بالتالي هم يريدون ان ينخرطوا بشكل
فردي مع اوكرانيا
كيف يمكن ان ترد روسيا على تطوير الانتاج
وتوطين الانتاج انتاج الاسلحه داخل
اوكرانيا
الواقع انتاج الاسلحه في اوكرانيا اي
انتاج الذخيره من عيار
155 للدبابات والمدافع هذا ضرب من الخيال
لان المانيا على سبيل المثال التي تعتبر
احد الدول القياديه بانتاج هذه الذخيره
تستطيع ان تنتج في العام حوالي
قاذفه هذا يعني انهم
يستطيعوا انتاج
صواريخ وقذائف لثلاثين يوم من المعارك
لذلك هذا يعني ان حتى المانيا في
مستودعاتها لديها ذخيره تكفي لثلاث ايام
من المعارك لذلك مات يحاول القيام به في
اوكرانيا هو طلب الاستثمارات اللي انشاء
هذه المصارع اين سوف تكون هذه المصانع اذا
ما جمعت في مكان واحد في المانيا او في
اوكرانيا هذا يعني انها ستدمر بصاروخين
الكنجاو اذا كان
الاوكران يريدون سرقه الاموال فهذا شيء
اخر
يعني هل الاوكران والغرب بهذه السذاجه لكي
يقوم ببناء مصانع مكشوفه ويمكن تدميرها
بهذه السهوله
ليسوا بالحمقى ولكن الاغلب هنا ان هناك
خداع من جانبين اوكرانيا تريد ان تحصل على
الاموال اما الغرب يريد ان يقللوا من
الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا بالاسلحه اذا
الغرب يخدع اوكرانيا واوكرانيا تريد ان
تغش الغرب وليس هناك شيء ثالث لانه كما
قلت لك اني في اليوم الواحد هناك حوالي
7000 قذيفه تستخدم
بالمدفعيه التي تقوم باطلاق هذه الذخائر
بشكل مستمر يوميا فاذا بدات اوكرانيا
بانتاج هذه
الذخائر قد تستطيع ان تنتج حوالي 17 الى
20 الف قذيفه
فاذا ما استطاعت ان تقوم بهذا في النصف
عام سوف تنتج ما يكفيها
لسته ايام فقط لذلك هذا اشبه ما يكون
بالخداع وهذا مفهوم للجميع خاصه لروسيا
لان الذخيره المنتجه في روسيا ارخص من
الغربيه بست مرات اسمع من العقيد داليا
عقيد داليا يعني روسيا تستهدف البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه وتستهدف ايضا مصانع
صناعه الاسلحه في اوكرانيا حاليا كيف يمكن
تجاوز
مشكله البنيه التحتيه وبناء المصانع
مستقبلا
الى الامور في بدايه الحرب كانت
اوكرانيا تنتج حوالي خمسين
كانت تواجه هذه الهجمات لكن الان هنالك
تصاعد بالتالي القليل من الصواريخ الروسيه
والمسارات تحقق اهدافها والان ايضا
اوكرانيا تصعد من امكانياتها الدفاعيه
ايضا بالتالي لا اعتقد ان روسيا ربما
ستكون قادره على استهداف هذه المصانع بشكل
بهذه السهوله عقيد ليام هل تعتقد بان
البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه مجهزه لصناعه
الاسلحه بهذه السهوله او السرعه
اي شكل لديهم
شركه كبيره يسمها
هي انتجت الاسلحه ومنذ بدايه الحرب روسيا
لم تتمكن من استهداف هذه الامكانيات
بالتالي ما تحاول اوكرانيا القيام به هو
تسريع هذه كانت تقوم به من بدايه الحرب هي
تحاول ان تستقطب الاستثمارات والشركات
الغربيه لكي تزيد من انتاجها محليا سيد
فلاديمير ذكرت بان اوكرانيا لن تستطيع
انتاج ما يكفيها ولكن رئيس الوزراء
الاوكراني يقول انه لن يطرا اي تغيير في
موقف الشركاء الغربيين بشان دعم كييف
عسكريا اذا ما ياتي من انتاج محلي يضاف
الى الدعم الغربي وليس بديلا عنه
سيدي
يضاعف الانتاج المحلي هم بحاجه كوادر
مدربه ومتخصصه الذين سوف ينتجوا الحديد
اليات المتخصصه في هذه المصانع وهم ليس
لديهم امكانيات لهذا كل الرجال هم الان في
المعارك
وهناك حوالي اربع الاف شخص يقتله يوميا
وحوالي ثمانيه فرق قضى عليها في خطوط
التماس لم يبقى لديهم اي رجال فمن اين
سياتوا بالمتخصصين من المهندسين
طيب للاسف لم يعد هنالك وقت فلاديمير بيرا
النسيان الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي كنت
معنا من موسكو ومن ويسكنسن العقيد لينكونز
المستشار السابق لوزير الدفاع الامريكي
لشؤون اوكرانيا شكرا لكما
حذر الرئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن
مكارتي من عبور اكثر من 50 الف شخص من
طالبين لجوء حدود بلاده قادمين من المكسيك
بشكل غير قانوني خلال الاسبوع الحالي
مطالبا بانتهاج السياسات اكثر صرامه للحد
من ذلك وتتركز موجات العبور في مدينه ايجل
باس في ولايه تكساس الامريكيه على الحدود
مع المكسيك ورغم شريط الاسلاك الشائكه
الذي دشنه الحرس الوطني على ضفه نهر ريو
غراندي الفاصل بين ولايه تكساس والمكسيك
فان طالبي اللجوء واغلبيتهم من فنزويلا
يواصلون عبور النهر وتسليم انفسهم لسلطات
الحدود الامريكيه
خرج متظاهرون في باريس ومدن فرنسيه اخرى
للتمديد بمشروع قانون الهجره الجديد
وللمطالبه بتوفير شروط سكن مناسبه للجميع
بمن فيهم المهاجرون غير النظاميين وقال
المحتاجون ان القانون الجديد يعقد يعقد
تسويه الوضع القانوني للمهاجرين غير
النظاميين في فرنسا ويسهل عمليه ترحيلهم
وتنص بنود في القانون الجديد على تشديد
مكافحه الهجره غير النظاميه وتسهيل طرد
الاجانب الذين لا يحترمون قيم الجمهوريه
وفقا لتصريحات وزير الداخليه الفرنسي
في بريطانيا يتزايد عدد الذين يتركون
وظائفهم لاسباب عده منها الضغط النفسي
وفقدان السيطره على حياتهم الخاصه والرغبه
في اقامه مشاريع تمنحهم مرونه ومزيدا من
التحدي وبحسب الدراسات البريطانيه فان
كثيرين من من اقاموا مشاريعهم الخاصه
العام الماضي اعترفوا بان الامر لم يكن
سهلا كما كانوا يتوقعون بينما اجبر معظمهم
على تعلم خبرات جديده لتحقيق النجاح
[موسيقى]
تبدو فيكتوريا مستمتعه بتحذير هذا النوع
من الفطائر التي اتخذت منها حرفه بعد ترك
وظيفه تقول انها جلبت لها الكابه وعرضتها
لضغوط نفسيه كثيره
في حصه للعلاج النفسي وكنت حزينه للغايه
فسالتني المعالجه ما اذا كان الامر يتعلق
بوظيفه قلت لها نعم لكن لا يمكنني تركها
فكيف لا نترك وظيفه مستقره مقابل لا شيء
فقالت لي انك تحبين الطبخ وبامكانك القيام
بشيء ما مرت على ذلك سنوات واصبح لعمل خاص
واصبحت سعيده
تقول فيكتوريا ان عملها الحرا انعكس ايضا
ايجابا على عائلتها وحياتها الاجتماعيه
وهي ليست استثناء فاغلبيه الموظفين
البريطانيين يرغبون في ترك وظائفهم
والتوجه نحو اعمال حره
ويعزوا هؤلاء ذلك الى اسباب منها الرغبه
في العمل لحسابهم الخاص والتحكم في اداره
حياتهم الخاصه وزياده الثروه هنا على
ابواب حي المال والاعمال اللندني مثلا
تختلف الصوره نوعا ما فليس كل الموظفين
قادرين على ترك وظائفهم
مراقبه
هل اترك وظيفه الروتينيه لا لا اعتقد ذلك
لان تخصصي في العمل المكتبي وان تركت
الوظيفه فساكون كما يطلق النار على رجله
انك تقوم بعمل لكن مساوئ الوظيفه بالنسبه
لي في التنقل لانني اسكن في الساحل
الجنوبي واقضي ساعتين ايابا وساعتين ذها
الى العمل
زياده الاهتمام بين الموظفين البريطانيين
باقامه مشاريعهم الخاصه تاتي في ظل اوضاع
اقتصاديه مترديه في البلاد
اغلب هؤلاء يعترفون بان التحديات التي
واجهتهم كانت اكبر مما توقعوا ولتحقيق
النجاح اضطر معظمهم الى اكتساب خبرات
جديده
الامر ليس سهلا لكي تنجح لابد لك من
الانضباط والا تتوقع النجاح خلال شهرين
لان ذلك لن يحدث انت بحاجه الى ان تكون
واقعيا وجادا وان تكتسب خبرات جديده
والاهم ان تحافظ على الاستمراريه
فكل يوم يحمل معه تحديا جديدا وهذا ما
كانت تبحث عنه وهو ما يحفزها على
الاستمرار
من حرب اللغه الجزيره لندن
[موسيقى]
فقره المتابعه في حصاد الليله نخصصها
لمشروع قانون الهجره الجديد المطروح في
فرنسا نقاش ساخن جدا متوقع خلال عرض مشروع
القانون للتصويت امام البرلمان وسط مطالب
احزاب يمنيه بتشديده وفي غياب اجماع بشانه
سبق ان اوضح الرئيس امام مكرون ان خيار
استخدام الماده الدستوريه التاسعه
والاربعين لتمرير القانون الهجره الجديد
غير مستبعد ومن بين ابرز النقاط التي
يتضمنها المشروع الجديد للهجره تسهيل
ابعاد المهاجرين غير النظاميين الى
بلدانهم الاصليه خاصه اولئك الذين ارتكبوا
جنحا وذلك بتقليص سبل استئناف الحكم امام
المحاكم ولم تتعدى نسبه المبعدين حاليا من
فرنسا العشره في المئه من اجمالي المقيمين
فيها دون بطاقه الاقامه وافقه وزاره
الداخليه الفرنسيه اما الماده الثانيه
فتنص على تغيير طرق من اللجوء السياسي
للاجانب في فرنسا وتقليص مده دراسه
الملفات من سنه او اكثر حاليا الى سته
اشهر فقط ويراد من هذه الماده التسريع في
ابعاد كل الذين لم يتمكنوا من الحصول على
اللجوء السياسي في فرنسا بعد ان تتم دراسه
ملفاتهم الاداريه كما يهدف القانون الجديد
ايضا
لتسويه اوضاع المهاجرين غير النظاميين
الذين يمارسون وظائف في مجالات تفتقد الى
اليد العامله في فرنسا كالمطاعم وقطاع
البناء والنقل عبر منحهم بطاقه اقامه
قابله للتجديد يقترح القانون منحى من
يعملون في القطاعات المذكوره على الاراضي
الفرنسيه لمده ثمانيه اشهر متتاليه
الاقامه لمده ثلاث سنوات على ان لا تتضمن
حق لم الشمل لعائلاتهم
قدر عدد المهاجرين في فرنسا في 2021
بسبعه ملايين بحسب دراسه ديموغرافيه ترصد
للمره الاولى منذ عشر سنوات تطور الهجره
على مدى عده اجيال اشار المعهد الوطني
الفرنسي للاحصاء والدراسات الاقتصاديه في
وثيقه بعنوان المهاجرون واحفاد المهاجرين
في فرنسا اشار الى ان اكثر من 10% من
السكان الذين يعيشون في فرنسا مهاجرون
اكثر من ثلثها هؤلاء حصلوا على الجنسيه
الفرنسيه منذ وصولهم من بين احفاد
المهاجرين فان اكثر من 50% من ابناء الجيل
الثاني لديهم احد الوالدين مهاجر فقط
بينما لدى تسعه من اصل عشره من ابناء
الجيل الثالث الذين لديهم جد مهاجر واحد
على الاقل جد او اثنان من المهاجرين
اما الاصول فمختلفه بحيث كان المهاجرون
ياتون اساسا من جنوب اوروبا قبل 50 عاما
اما اليوم فياتون بشكل اساسيا من المغرب
العربي او من افريقيا او اسيا
تشير الدراسه الى ان الهجره تتركز في
المدن الكبرى بحيث يشكل المهاجرون نسبه
20% من سكان باريس واثنين في المئه من
ساندوني الضاحيه الشعبيه شمال العاصمه
وكشفت ايضا الدراسه ان المهاجرين في فرنسا
اكثر ارتباطا بالدين من بقيه السكان بحيث
يحتل الاسلام المرتبه الاولى حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم الينا من باريس كابرييل لا
تنزو الاكاديمي والناشط الحقوقي سيد
جابريال بدايه ما تقييمكم لمشروع القانون
هذا
انه
حلقه من سلسله طويله في حقيقه الامر
الهجره لسنوات العشره او الخمسه عشره
الماضيه لم تكن القضيه الاهم في الحياه
السياسيه في فرنسا لكن كما راينا خلال
السنوات الماضيه هي اصبحت قضيه متناميه
تزيد من التوتر ما نعرفه هو ان من المحتمل
بشكل كبير ان يقوم اليمين المتطرف في
فرنسا سيزداد قوه خلال سنوات القادمه
لربما قد يسيطرون على السلطه في عام 2027
انا لا ادعو لهذا الامر بالتاكيد لكنني ما
متاكد منه ان الهجره قد تم مناقشتها بعده
طرق ومن عده جهات ثقافيه
مشروع القانون هذا هل هو قادر على
الموازنه بين حقوق الانسان والحقوق
الطبيعيه لاي مهاجر ومصالح فرنسا
[موسيقى]
ثمانيه اشهر متتاليه لكن لا يسمح لهم بلم
الشمل مع عائلاتهم هل هذا انساني
على الاطلاق لان بدانا بالاقتصاد اولا
وجعلنا الانسان اخيرا اعتقد ان المجتمع
الصحي يجب ان يبدا بالانسان اذا ما
سالتيني براي الشخصي السؤال الذي يجب ان
نجيبه هو كيف بامكاننا ان نضمن ان الناس
يشعرون انهم
باننا جميعا بشر ولدينا نفس الحقوق وهذا
هو السؤال الاصعب ما الذي يجعل ما الذي
يخلق التضامن بين الناس لا اعتقد ان الامر
يتعلق بالمال فقط هذه قصه نخبرها لانفسنا
والحقيقه هي ان بوجود الهجره ام لا هنالك
الكثير من التوتر والانقسام في العالم
واعتقد ان علينا مسؤوليه تقع علينا جميعا
من اجل ان نقدم هذه المقارب مقاربه المصير
المشترك وهذا بالنسبه ليس فقط لا ينطبق
على الشعب الفرنسي لكن على الشعوب شعوب
العالم في الشرق الاوسط وفي اسيا وفي اي
مكان اعتقد اننا نفشل في هذا الامر شكرا
لك من باريس جابرييل لا تنسو الاكاديمي
والنشاط الحقوقي
بهذا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد تصبحون على الف
خير
[موسيقى]